For the next couple of weeks we will be examining the uh.
Coming and the fighting of the great Peloponnesian War.
It's a subject that had tremendous importance for the Greeks themselves and it
has been one of the things that has occupied people interested in the ancient
Greeks more than most things.
Partly because of its own extraordinary importance.
But I think perhaps even more because of the fact that it was described for us
by a participant a contemporary lucidity is the son of a loris and Athenian Who
by common consent throughout the millennia has been agreed upon as one of the
great
historians of ever is sort of the second one that we know of in all of history
but also one who is much esteemed.
I would argue that right now he is probably esteemed more than he has ever been
throughout the history of the world because he's had such a great influence on
thinking in the west and then in the world as well around the world as well.
Ever since the 20th century he really came into his own as events like the first
and the second world war to be followed then by the cold war seemed to observers
of the time to be much illuminated by studying to sit in his account of the
Peloponnesian War and as a consequence his own way of thinking about history and
about war and about international relations and about behavior of human beings
in the mass and a whole variety of subjects in the realm of politics and
diplomacy and war.
So it's for those reasons I think that this story has been so carefully looked
at compared to others in history.
You know that for almost three decades at the end of the 5th century the
Athenian Empire fought against the Spartan alliance in this terrible war that
changed the Greek world and the civilization of the Greeks forever.
From the perspective of the fifth century Greeks the Peloponnesian War deserves
to be thought of I think as a world war.
You know I'm sorry.
It just involves the Greeks themselves.
And that's not quite right.
It's one of the points the cities makes.
It drew into it.
Other peoples other than the Greeks who were very important to Persians where
they play a critical role.
And similarly the Macedonians and similarly peoples in Sicily and in Italy.
So it really doesn't require much defense from the Greek point of view to think
of it as a kind of a World War a critical turning point in Greek history causing
enormous destruction of life and property intensifying factional and class.
Hostility dividing the Greek states internally.
It was the cause of civil wars throughout the Greek world throughout its history
and subsequently destabilising the relationship of classes within cities and
between and the relationships between cities ultimately as we can see from
hindsight.
Making the capacity of the Greeks to resist an outside threat much weaker and
helping to bring about a situation in which they finally did lose their
independence their autonomy.
So from so many points of view the war may be seen as a tragic event the end of
a period of confidence and hope.
And I would want to stress that if you look at the 50 year stretch between the
Persian War and the Peloponnesian War it is the Great Age of Greece when so many
of the things that we value in the experience of the Greeks were created and
carried forward
and a period in which one sees evidence of all sorts of confidence in human
capacities and the hope of what will be in the future all of that I think
suffered a considerable reversal by because of the Peloponnesian War and begin a
darker time.
It was a war of unprecedented brutality in Greek life violating even the already
rugged code that had previously governed Greek fighting and breaking through
that thin veneer that separates civilization from savagery.
And it is actually two subsidiaries that that way of thinking about things is Oh
certainly for me.
That's when I first understood what he's teaching us to such a degree in his
history that there is just a very thin veneer that covers over the brutal the
bestial the worst and bestial that exists in human beings even in society but
that society is what makes that covers that over and permit something resembling
what we would call civilization but warfare tends to put a strain on that
limiting element which is what society gives you.
Anger frustration the desire for vengeance increases as the fighting drags on
producing a progression of atrocities that included maiming and killing captured
opponents throwing them into pits to die of thirst starvation and exposure.
That's what happened in Sicily and hurling them into the sea to drown which
became the practice.
Towards the end of the Peloponnesian War is a case of a band of marauders
murdering innocent schoolchildren entire cities were destroyed.
The men kill the women and children sold into slavery.
I don't say there were no atrocities before the Peloponnesian War but nothing
like the concentration of them that developed and also I suspect a whole new
range of them also came into being.
One reason being that in the past wars had been short.
And one of the messages I think lucidity is wants to give us is that the longer
a war persists the more inevitable is the sinking below the civilized levels of
warfare.
If there is such a thing as a civilized level of warfare to a much more horrible
way of fighting.
And as I said although the war ended over twenty four hundred years ago it
continues to fascinate readers today.
I was astonished.
I wrote a one volume history of the Peloponnesian War so fifty thousand copies
of the damn thing
I was.
I truly have made so it was my publisher.
But but I think I shouldn't have been amazed because for.
Four maybe a century now people have been studying facilities and the war.
Or when they have not been studying them and hearing about it.
References have been made to it.
By distinguished people General Marshall referred to it in a famous quotation
when he was secretary of state.
And people keep talking about it.
And so the curiosity I think rather than the familiarity curiosity about what is
this all about may account for this but it's also true that if you go to add the
two cities in the Peloponnesian War are taught.
In all the military academies they are taught in all just about I've never heard
one that didn't in all programs of international relations anywhere.
That's one of the first books along with the Chinese sage of warfare sun to both
of those seem to be typically read everywhere and and so on.
And it's not that I don't think that this is just an affectation and look at us.
We read classical stuff.
I don't think that's what it's about.
I think it is based on a conviction and supported by arguments by scholars not
classes is that there is some continuing meaning some continuing value something
we can learn about all of these important topics by reading facility.
So I want to just comfort you for the burden I've laid on you and giving you
that book and all of this stuff to read you're not wasting your time.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
I'd like to turn first to the question of the origins of the war the causes of
the war the outbreak of the war however you want to look at that phenomenon
because facilities is very interested in that subject and writes about it with a
sophistication that in my opinion has not been proved superseded and rarely
matched in the years since that point.
To sit on these whole first book really is about that subject.
How and why.
Did that war come about.
And that's a subject I just think is immensely interesting and important
because.
We should face the fact that the history of civilized mankind is almost the
history of warfare.
There's nothing more typical of human societies than that they are organized to
fight wars and do so.
So and I think by the 20th 21st century we ought to have come to the conclusion
this is a bad thing.
War is certainly now whatever positive functions they might have had in the past
and they have been sometimes glorified it for various reasons.
The price of them is just far too high for us to think that's fine.
Let's keep doing that.
So that's the problem.
Why do wars happen and how can they be avoided.
It strikes me as important a question as there is and subsidiaries I think gives
us some some food to chew on as we think about that.
Well he examined the situation in the first book and concluded with what he
calls the truest cause the truest explanation although our quote him now the
truest explanation although it has been the least often advanced I believed to
have been the growth of the Athenians to greatness which brought fear to the
last to die moaning ends and force them to war
scholars differ a bit on what that really means.
But I side with what I think of the majority the scholars on this point which is
to say he is really saying that this war.
Became Inevitable at a certain point when the Athenian Empire.
That's the greatness of Athens reached such a point as to alarm.
The Spartans enough to do what they did which was to start a war to check the
growth of that Athenian power.
Everything I've said is open to criticism and disagreement and just naturally
great big arguments about these things.
But I'm giving you my view which is not original or unique
now.
I think it's important to realize that two cities does not think that sort of an
obvious explanation can be found by examining the circumstances that took place
when the war broke out in 431 B.C. and the proof of that is not merely that he
speaks about the truest explanation which means he's rejecting less true ones
which do focus on the events themselves.
What we might call the precipitating causes of the war.
He begins his account explaining how the war came to two back to the end of the
Persian Wars and the events that are important from his point of view are the
forming of the Dalian League which emerges as the Athenian Empire.
That's one critical thing.
He goes back to the other critical thing he goes back to is the distrust that
emerged swiftly between Athens and Sparta which turned into a major division in
the Greek world and produced ultimately the suspicion obviously is something
that makes it easier to bring about fear.
And so we get to that second element that through Saturday's talks about the
fear that the growth of Athenian power engendered in the Spartans and what is so
splendid in my eyes about some cities understanding of why these things happen
and why it's so superior to what is typically taught in the graduate schools
that it study international relations is he's talking about human emotions.
He's talking about feelings.
He's not talking about structures that you need to be a professor in order to
understand.
I think that that's one of the powerful things lucidity is as interested in
structures the first one ever looks at it thinks it's a very important thing but
when it comes down to explaining why nations go to war he looks at the feelings
that the people involved have.
Well we've talked already about some of the events that he describes taking them
mainly from him.
I'm talking about the the beginning of the Dalian league conversion into an
Athenian Empire the suspicion that aroused among the Spartans.
But the fact that they worked things out until until this.
The phases in rebellion where we see the Athenians.
Acting more aggressively with less less justification than they ever have
before.
But what I didn't tell you because I wanted to save it for this context is that
there's two cities mentions the fact that.
When the Salesians launched their rebellion against Athens in 465 they went
first to the Spartans and asked them if we rebel against the Athenians will you
invade Attica.
And the F wars the the officials that conduct foreign policy in the first
instance in Sparta said they would
well they didn't because before they could do so the great earthquake occurred
which prevented them doing any such thing.
It needs to be pointed out that this message that these talks that went on
between the Asians and the Spartans were secret and we have to believe that at
this time the Athenians did not know about these conversations because if they
had there is no way they could have been persuaded to send help 4000 hop flights
into the Peloponnese just to help the Spartans against the highlights.
So I think we need to.
I think we need to accept facilities assessment of that situation.
Well we know what happened.
The Athenians were sent away because of the suspicion that the Spartans felt for
them and their way of government and this produced a tremendous anger in the
Athenians and it also led to a revolution internally in which the communion
regime was replaced by one led by more radical democrats like Effie outis and
Pericles and also a diplomatic revolution in which the Athenians withdrew from
the Greek league under Spartan leadership and in which they made alliances first
with our gods the great enemy of Sparta and then with the aliens whom they hope
would supply them with useful cavalry in case of a future war.
So those are all that's that's a terrific takeoff point for the first quarrel of
seriousness between the two sides which modern historians call the first
Peloponnesian War.
One other thing that happened at the conclusion of this previous period that is
to say with the
with the end of that with the withdrawal of the Athenians from the scene the
Spartans finally took care of the hell.
They never were able really to defeat them and get them down from their fort up
on Mount.
It's not me but they finally made a deal with the people up there saying we will
allow you to come down and safety and go away some place so long as you leave
the Peloponnese is they undoubtedly expected that the hell lots would then be
scattered one to one here one there one other place where else would they go.
That's what would have happened had it not been that the Athenians who had
lately acquired we know not how.
Control of a town on the north shore of the Corinthian Gulf called not practice
it is so it has a very good harbour and it is so located as to be wonderful as a
naval base for somebody who wished to be able to control access to the
Corinthian Gulf the Athenians took it and then turned it over to the harlots who
had fled the Peloponnese.
That was not what the Spartans had in mind although there was nothing in the
deal that prevented them from this from being done but it means the Athenians
had done another bit of harm to the Spartans putting their bitter enemies in a
position to cause trouble to them and to their allies on the Corinthian Gulf.
So all of that suggests that on the next day and so to speak after all of these
changes had taken place the world was very different and the prospects I would
have thought for peace between Sparta and her allies in Athens and her allies
had been badly reduced is no longer an association between the two
the Athenians have allied themselves with Spartan enemies the Athenians have
taken a hell lots and put them in this terrific place.
This is not a recipe for good relations in the future and it would only.
This is where the cliché seems to me to be useful people talk about a powder keg
which only needs a spark to set it off into a great explosion.
People use this about the outbreak of many wars sometimes it's an apt.
Thing and sometimes it's not.
This time I think it is as we shall see.
It didn't take very much to produce an explosion between Athens and Sparta.
After these events
and the I guess the spark was provided by a quarrel that took place between two
Spartan allies in the Peloponnese as Majora and Karen's neighbors on that
isthmus that leads into northern and added northern Greece and into Athens.
And since they're both members of this of the Spartan alliance
the Spartans had choices to make about what was happening and the choice was
soon forced upon them because when it was clear that the Corinthians were
winning the argument
winning the war I should say that they were fighting against Megaman.
Mike Arians came to Sparta and asked them for their help in putting down this
war and ending it.
And the Spartans said no we're not interested it's your business not ours.
Now that's interesting.
We can't really tell because there's nothing written about it.
What obligations the Spartans had when two allies who are autonomous states
according to the theory decide to fight each other.
It looks to me because nobody complained about it in terms of constitutional
irregularity that the Spartans had every right to ignore what was going on.
We must assume I suppose that in the centuries or a century or so before the
Spartans must have ignored other quarrels between allies and allow them to fight
it out or settle it any way they want.
The Spartans don't give a damn who wins as between currents and Negara and why
should they get involved.
And I think that a hands off attitude must have been encouraged by the fact that
they had just probably was still recovering from the earthquake and the hell out
rebellion that came after it.
They really didn't need more trouble.
And so they let the thing go.
Now the reason the Spartans could take such a cavalier attitude in the past was
that they were the only great power in the Greek world.
But in 461 that was not true.
The losers Negara had a choice.
They could and did go to Athens and say won't you help us against cards if you
do we will leave the Peloponnesian league and join the Athenian side.
Now that is brought about as I say by the new circumstances.
This is one of those places where those of us who remember the Cold War are
immediately struck by similarities.
There were troubles all over the world so long as it was known that NATO was on
one side and the Soviet Union and Warsaw Pact was on the other.
All kinds of places that neither had any interests and would call on when they
were in a war or some kind of a fight in their own places Africa for instance
they would go to one side or the other and say help us or we will seek help from
your enemy.
And that confronted each side with a hard problem.
I don't give a damn what happens in country X you might say but I don't want the
Russians there and vice versa.
This is the kind of problem that one sees in this situation.
So the Athenians were confronted by an extremely tough decision.
I want to try to communicate to you my sense of how difficult the calls are in
this situation.
Now one natural reaction would be this.
It seems to me why in the world should we accept this defection from the
Peloponnesian league because it's bound to anger the Spartans and very likely
bring us a war with the pelican nations which is a very hard thing to face.
What do we care about the quarrel between Maga and Carmen the opposite
assumptions would be.
No we don't care about who wins between current and Negara but we do care about
having mega on our side.
Because if we control mega if the McGarry ends are on our side Negara is
situated on the the side of the isthmus right next to Athens.
And more than that there's a mountain range that runs through mega.
That makes it very difficult for somebody to make his way through that territory
if they are opposed by military force.
In short with the help of the mega Aryans the Athenians could cut off access.
To Athens and probably for the most part to central Greece to the Spartans.
Let me put it more sharply.
The Athenians could feel invulnerable to a Spartan attack if they could control
Negara.
Now they would have to know that if they took this offer it might bring a war
with with Sparta.
But there would have been plenty of Athenians who would have thought that is
going to happen anyway.
The only question before us is do we want to do have a war with Sparta.
On these wonderfully positive conditions or do we want to fight it in the old
way in which we have no way to stop the Spartans from marching into our
territory and destroying our fields.
And in fact defeating us because the Athenians as yet had not built walls
connecting Athens with the port of Piraeus so that the Spartans could cut the
Athenians off from their port just by invading their territory.
And as we know the Athenians do not produce enough food to feed themselves so
these would be the thoughts that were going through the minds of the Athenians
and noticed the critical element in your decision.
It seems to me is your prediction about what is likely in the future.
If you think there really is not a danger of a war with Sparta why bring it on.
But if you think there is a real danger of a war with Sparta why leave
yourselves vulnerable to the Spartans.
Whichever call you make there are dangers and uncertainties at the other end
which I simply say welcome to the real world.
It's almost always that way.
And it's a beautiful lesson in how real those hard decisions are.
Well they seem indecision was to take mega into the Athenian alliance and to
take the dangers that went with that and to make their their task easier.
They built.
Long Walls connecting the city of Majora with the Port of New savior on the
on the Gulf the Savannah Gulf which is where Athens is located as well and also
to gain control of the town of Pega which is on the I guess I'd say the northern
side of the Isthmus and to fortify it and put forces between there.
In other words to build.
A barrier to Spartan capacity to move into Attica that was the great gain that
they made of it.
One of the great prices they paid to acidity says this in his own voice.
This he says was the beginning of Corinthian hatred for Athens.
It is a fact if you look at Corinthian Athenian relations in the past there.
We don't know a lot about them but what we know suggests that they were not
unfriendly.
They did OK.
No problems really between them.
But from now on you're going to have tremendous trouble with.
And this as you know from reading your subsidiaries and your textbook.
Currents will play a critical role in 431 in bringing on the Peloponnesian War.
That is the Great War.
So that was one of the prices the Athenians paid for this decision.
Now if you apply to sit his judgment to the great Peloponnesian War and you
forget that apply it to this situation it seems to me to bring very very true.
You said you remember that the growing power of the Athenians caused fear among
the Spartans and led them and forced them to war.
Well there's no question that the Athenian power has grown these alliances that
they have just made and this new geopolitical advantage they have gained through
their alliance with Maghreb suddenly make Athens much more formidable.
And there's no question that the Spartans become fearful about that and
ultimately as we shall see fearful enough to join in a war against the
Athenians.
So I agree with facilities if you're talking about the first Peloponnesian War.
But that's not what he's talking about when we get the one great question that I
would like to confront
when we get to the big war is does it work.
Does his evaluation of work for the big I should warn you at once that most
scholars throughout the years have accepted Cincinnati's explanation and
interpretation of the great Peloponnesian War.
And I don't so be careful.
He was there.
He knows much more about it than I do.
He's much smarter than I am.
So if I say he's wrong I better have a good case.
That's all I can say.
Well.
Not much.
We need not say very much about the war in detail.
Essentially the Athenians took the initiative and in a general way when they
fought battles at sea they won when they fought battles on land.
They didn't.
No great battles were fought for a couple of years that the fighting took place
in and around the eastern Peloponnese for the most part and nothing decisive
happened.
Then we get down towards the year for fifty seven.
I keep warning you that the dates here are uncertain but we know these are sort
of consensus dates although we don't have certainty
Athenians received an invitation from
a ruler in Egypt who wanted to launch a rebellion against the Persian Empire.
And he invited the Athenians to send a force to help the Athenians agreed to do
it.
And according to facilities they sent a fleet of two hundred ships for the
purpose.
That's an enormous fleet up to this point.
The Athenians by now have a fleet that's bigger than that.
And they can afford to do it.
But I want you to understand this is a major undertaking.
Now
why did they do it.
They do it because the opportunities in Egypt are tremendous.
Egypt is the greatest grain grower in the Mediterranean area and we know the
Athenians are always interested in sources of grain.
But Egypt is fantastically wealthy because of its great fertility.
And so the Athenians if they can gain a share of that wealth will of course
profit from that.
And finally if the seniors are still officially at war with Persia.
So it's perfectly reasonable to try to strip the Persians of possibly their
richest province.
All of those things make their decision understandable.
Now on the other hand you might ask the question now you know you're engaged in
a war with various Peloponnesian and that although the Spartans haven't taken
any action yet you can expect some from them.
Is this a great time for you to tackle yet another war against the Persians.
Well they thought so and I think it's evidence of the tremendous confidence that
the Athenians had acquired by this time.
And as we shall see it was overconfidence of course this whole story fits
beautifully into Greek feelings Greek ideas Greek religion and mythology.
This will be a beautiful example if Herodotus were writing the history instead
of the very very I'd want to say atheistic lucidity.
I'm not sure he was an atheist but was certainly very very skeptical about it
this would have been talking about hubris all over the place because that's the
kind of situation that we have but let's let's let's forget about that Athenian
force in Egypt for the time being.
And let's look at what the situation is in the year 457.
We have a wonderful piece of evidence rare piece of evidence actually an
inscription from that year
which is a part of a dedication a funeral dedication from a single Athenian
tribe in which they list the war dead from their tribe by where they fought and
died.
And they and they're proud of this.
I mean of course they're proud of the heroism of their men but they're proud I
think also about the range of places that they're fighting unheard of.
One example in all of Greek history in Egypt Sunni Shia Halifax which is a town
in the northeastern Peloponnese is e Jinnah the great island that sits in the
Serrano golf opposite Athens.
A China being a great traditional enemy of Athens and mega.
Of course as you know.
So here they are fighting battles and all of these places at the same time.
It's a it's a kind of a eight man pounding on his chest to show how great he was
a piece of arrogance you might say calling for vengeance by the gods but no
vengeance came right away.
Instead another victory in China the island of Regina was taken by the Athenians
Regina had been a great naval power.
So here was a naval power taken away from the enemy and added to the Athenian
side.
They now have without question although they've had it really before command of
the seas.
Nobody can withstand them at sea.
And they now have complete security from their North Western frontier because of
the McCarran alliance.
And that's not all that happened.
Finally moved I would guess in part by seeing all of this happening and worrying
desperately about the growing power of Athens Sparta took action.
I think they were moved specifically the critical element that was an
opportunity presented to them by.
A small region in central Greece called Doris steel.
I guess.
It's the root of the word Dorian.
This is theoretically the ancestral home of all Dorian's.
So they obviously had friendly relations with the Spartans.
The Dorian's were having trouble with some of their neighbors.
One of the standard quarrels between neighbors in the Greek city state world.
And they asked the Spartans to send a force up to help them.
I'm not sure that the Spartans would have done so in the normal course of events
because it does mean that they have to get up to central Greece.
When you think about that given what the Athenians have done in Maira they can't
do it in the usual way by walking.
The only way they can get up there is by getting on boats and sailing across the
Corinthian Gulf.
But if the Athenians or those harlots who are occupying no practice are aware of
that they could very well be tagged taken at sea and had their have their army
destroyed as that fleet is sunk.
They have to sneak across if they're going to go that way.
I want you to understand how unlikely is that undertaking in a normal situation.
But what I think makes it not so normal is something that dire Doris of Sicily
tells us facilities doesn't mention which is at that moment the theme ends.
The leading city of Bosnia which had ambitions of its own.
Always wanting to gain complete control of Bosnia and always having some big
ocean cities hold out against them.
They saw the opportunity to get the Spartans to help them out.
And so they told the Spartans that if they would come and assist them in gaining
control of the OCA the big oceans would join them in an attack on Athens.
And so I think it was that that made it possible for the Spartans to agree and
to act
they do so they take an army much more than they need to deal with the Dorian
problem.
They slapped that down right away and then what do you know.
They come marching down to the Athenian frontier with B OCA to a town or place
near a town called Tana gra
the Spartans of course were able to sneak across the edge of the Gulf of carts.
You may ask why were the Athenians and the hell out so sleepy.
It never occurred to them is what I say.
The Spartans would ever do a thing like that.
And so there they were.
The
battle is then fought and we we're talking about large forces and now the
Spartans send 11000 men.
That's a very big.
They don't have 11000 of their own Spartans end up helping Asian allies go up
there and now they are put together with the ocean forces.
The oceans are very good fighters.
The Athenians send their army out to the frontier to meet them.
It's the greater part of the Athenian army.
This is a very big battle by Greek standards and the result is almost a
standoff.
The Spartans technically win and that means that they were able to command the
field after the fighting was over.
Put up a trophy
collect their own dead.
The Athenians of course were required to come and ask them for permission to
collect their dead so there wasn't any question if you follow the rules of hop
like warfare at the time who won the Spartans won.
But if we think of it from the standpoint of warfare and you ask about what were
the strategic consequences of the battle that's how today we would say who won
that battle.
It was a standoff and I guess you could say the Athenians won because the
purpose of the Spartans was to defeat the Athenians and to compel them to
abandon all the things that they were doing and had done.
And in this they failed because they had suffered heavy casualties in the
fighting and were not in a position to renew the battle and to force the
Athenians back or to crush the Athenians in fighting the Spartans simply marched
back into the Peloponnese as the Athenians were in no condition to stop them.
So that was that.
And as one sees from what happens after that it really looks more like a
strategic victory for the Athenians because now a they have not been destroyed
they have not been defeated in any useful way.
They have not been stopped in what they were doing and to prove it.
The Athenians take an army northward which is when the Spartans have withdrawn
into the ocean to.
Defeat the big ocean army at a place called enough Rita.
And the next thing you know establish democratic governments in all the big
ocean cities which are friendly to Athens.
I bet I put it that way.
But again in the cold war analogy strikes me as as helpful here in the same way
as wherever the Soviet Army.
Was victorious.
Whatever land they occupied there was a communist government set up whose
function was to be a tool of the Soviet Union.
I don't claim that that's exactly what it was in the 5th century.
It's a much more simple and less sophisticated world.
But the general idea is the same.
The guys who run those towns they are partisans of Athens Athens in other words
is the dominant force in the ocean.
I'll step back a moment.
Stand up there on the Acropolis in Athens and look around and you will see a
situation that is so splendid.
It's the kind of thing almost any nation would want as its ideal situation.
If you look to the north you're safe.
There can be no invasion through the ocean for the reasons I've just said.
If you look to the north west.
Megawatt an ally of yours your forces are in there in part but you have that
area blocked off.
There is no way and of course now that you know that the Spartans can take boats
across the Corinthian Gulf you'll see to it that that never happens again.
They're the Spartans and their allies are bottled up in the Peloponnese as the
sea is controlled completely by you.
I have also neglected to mention that the Athenians have just now concluded the
building of long walls connecting Athens with Piraeus.
So even if somehow hard to imagine as it is the Spartans got into Attica.
The Athenians need not fight them and need not give way to them because nobody
knows how to take walled cities very well anymore and the Spartans never learn
how to do it.
So if you look at it from that point of view until somebody invents an airplane.
Athens is absolutely invulnerable and they still have a two thousand year twenty
four hundred year leeway.
Two thousand years before anybody invents an airplane.
So
this is an amazing moment where you could readily think we are invulnerable.
We are safe.
We can do what we like with impunity.
I think this is a very important moment in Athenian and Greek history.
I think then there were Athenians who never got over remembering that's what we
achieved.
That's what we can achieve.
That's what we must aim for in all future circumstances.
And when we get into the Peloponnesian War and there come moments when it seems
possible that the Athenians can make a negotiated peace with the Spartans that's
OK in the war and they turned it down.
I think people subsidiaries and others suggest that they're just out of their
minds.
Maybe they are but they have something they can focus on.
A memory of how it once was and how it might be again.
Well
the gods are not going to put up with this you and I know that the Athenians
suffer a terrible reverse that begins to undermine their situation in Egypt.
There was a terrible disaster.
They lose the Persians defeat them.
There's a great argument about how many ships they lose but whatever it is they
lose a lot.
It makes they lose a strategically significant number
the disaster is so great as to cause a whole rash of rebellions in the dealing
in league or the Athenian Empire whatever you want to call it.
And the Athenians will be occupied with trying to put down these rebellions for
some time.
The situation by the way that the probable date of this defeat is probably
around four fifty five because it's in the following year and this date is a
good day for the 450 for three that the Athenians decide to move the treasury of
the league from de los to Athens up on the Acropolis in the back room of the
Parthenon which they will be building very shortly.
And another important point about that is up to now all money put into the
league Treasury was being used for supporting the Navy and ostensibly for league
purposes usually for league purposes.
But as we know the Athenians could also use it for their own purposes.
They did it faced us but still only four ships and men.
Now the Athenians instituted a new policy and I think whatever you think about
anything before this when the Athenians do what I'm about to describe they
surely have made this an Empire no longer anything like a voluntary Confederacy
because they take one sixtieth of what is put into the Treasury every year as a
donation to Athena which is another way of saying to Athens they are now.
Collecting a profit attacks from the league members which they as we shall see
there will be an argument about how this money is to be used.
They will argue it's our money we can use it any way we want to so that's two
things going in two different directions on the one hand.
All the trouble that they have in the league it leads them however to to change
the character of the league in a very significant way.
Things are so difficult.
The problem of fighting the Spartans now is so serious that the Athenians recall
came on because they would like to make peace with the Spartans and they know
came on is just the man to do it has no one else can.
And so he comes back how I should back up a second there was some talk about
chemo coming back earlier but he certainly comes back and 451 because his ten
years of ostracism are over and it's now that he negotiates a five years truce
with the Spartans with the understanding that the purpose of the truce is to
allow negotiation to go forward to bring about a long term peace agreement
between the two
came on achieves that and to show you how ostracism can work.
He is immediately elected General it's as though he had never gone away and
being came on he immediately turns to an activity that's a continuation of what
he did before he left namely let's go fight Persians.
And so he takes a fleet and sails to Cyprus which is in the part of which is in
Persian hands and fights a battle against the Persians defeats the Persians but
has the bad fortune to be killed.
And so came on is now removed from the scene in Athens.
I think this is a significant thing because it means that the only individual
politician who had the kind of support the kind of charisma the kind of backing
that could challenge the new important leader in Athens Pericles is gone.
And this helps explain why Pericles is still at a relatively young age and is
able to become a person of unprecedented influence and power in the Athenian
state.
It's not that he takes to himself new constitutional powers or gets military
guards or anything.
Nothing changes except that he can count on persuading the Assembly to do what
he wants.
Almost all the time and there is nobody out there for the moment who looks like
he can challenge him.
We shall see that shortly that he will meet an important challenge but will come
back to that later on.
But let's go on with the story of the war.
In 449 two years after the truce was negotiated we find Sparta attacking the
city of forces the policy forces again up in central Greece.
They must have.
Again.
We don't know how it was that they found their way up there but they did find
their way up there and they took back control of the Delphic Oracle from the
neighboring phones who had over the years they had frequently tried to gain
control of the Delphic Oracle from the priests and it was on behalf of those
priests that the Spartans Fought they defeated devotions and went home.
Two years later in 447 the Athenians sent an army up there.
They are seniors are allied to forces and they once again take back the Delphic
oracle and give it over to the potions.
These are signals that the truce is not really working that the two sides are
not finding a way to live together peacefully for the future.
And sure enough in the air for forty six a series of events occurs that upsets
the the peace and the balance that the Greek world had found for temporarily
first of all there is an oligarchic rebellion throughout the cities of the OCA
and of course they drive out the pro Athenian democratic regimes and suddenly B
OCA is a hostile place no longer a friendly place one from which the Athenians
can expect trouble there's a big argument in Athens as to So what should we do.
Parikh please says let's not do anything we really can't afford to engage in
ground campaigns against serious opponents.
We we tried it but we can't keep the OCA.
We'll just have to let the oceans go against him was a general and Athenian
general sometimes I'm astonished by the names that crop up in Athenian history.
You wouldn't dare do it you wouldn't invent names like this if you were writing
a novel because people would laugh here's this guy's name is tall Moody's it
comes from the Greek verb told model which means to be bold to be daring.
That's what he is bold and daring.
He marches an army into the ocean to get the place back for the Athenians.
In other words he defeated Pericles on this issue because you couldn't do that
with a get out getting the assembly's approval.
But the Athenians must have been mad too and said No let's go beat those big
oceans up and force them back into our control.
So might as runs into a terrific defeat suffers extremely heavy casualties by
anybody's standards and the OCA is lost for good the battle by the way in which
Tom Modise is killed is the battle of Caro and the CSIRO and a.
Athens is now driven from central Greece and that glorious picture I painted for
you has been marred by a hostile force on the northern enemy.
But that isn't all that's happened.
Seeing that the Athenians were troubled were weak were vulnerable and had can be
beaten.
Suddenly all of the unhappy folks that were around took advantage of the
opportunity on the island of Cuba to the east of Attica.
There is a rebellion.
This is really deadly from even from Pericles point of view.
He cannot permit rebellions in the Empire on islands.
It threatens the control of the sea.
It's not just that he can't have you be a be independent.
You cannot let rebels in your empire succeed because it encourages other
rebellions and they've just been through that.
They've had to fight their way through a whole rash of rebellions after the
defeat in Egypt.
So Pericles personally takes an army and sends it and takes it I should say too.
You'll be a
and while he is gone with his army often you'll be remembered with with the
ocean now hostile.
There is a rebellion in Majora.
This alliance with mega was always a very iffy thing.
We should remember two things about the past.
One is that mega Ora and Athens have been bitter enemies for centuries.
So the alliance was an unnatural one.
The product of momentary agreement but there would certainly have always been
lots of MC Aryans who were against.
And so seeing an opportunity these guys would have moved and the other thing
is that
the Athenians were of course being distracted and their forces were sent off
someplace else.
So now Pericles realizes how dangerous this is because if it meant if Negara
succeeds in the rebellion which it does now they have no protection from a
Spartan invasion which they need to expect and that is indeed what happens
proclaims.
Having put down that you'll be in rebellion adequately races back to Athens to
meet the Peloponnesian army when it invades and then we have this extraordinary
event in the plains to the north of Attica.
Spartans invade Pericles leads the Athenian army out to meet them this is the
scenario for a an Athenian defeat because the numbers of the palpitations are
likely to be greater and their reputation as a superior fighting force has some
merit.
We've seen that it's not going to be a walkover.
We've seen that the Athenians are capable of putting up one hell of a fight but
they can expect not to win is the way I see it.
So they are facing each other the battle is about to happen and all of a sudden
a delegation comes out from the Spartan army Pericles goes out to meet them.
They have a little conversation.
They all go back to their armies.
The Spartans led by their king Pleistocene Axel was one who was the guy who was
conferring with Pericles and marched their army back home to Sparta
they declare that they have agreed upon a four months truce for the purpose of
negotiating a permanent peace.
What in the world is going on here.
Well well the Spartans receive the news in a complicated way.
The first reaction is fury
against Pleistocene acts.
Why didn't you clobber those Athenians when you had them finally sticking their
heads out there for battle and they finally take action against him and against
his adviser.
Certain clearances and send them off to exile.
So angry are they at this lost opportunity.
But after all if that's all there was to it there was nothing to stop them from
marching into Attica again and either fighting against the Athenians or at least
doing terrible harm to the farms and the houses of the Athenians out in the
country which at the very least would make the Athenians unhappy and might force
them to come out and fight.
Why didn't they do that.
But they didn't.
And I think that's evidence.
Well it's evidence of two things.
There was a very special opportunity that place acts had lost namely everything
was falling apart on all fronts in Athens at the moment when the battle was
available on the other hand.
That's now.
They've been put down.
You'll be a is quiet and the Athenians have adjusted to everything else.
Still what I've said in the first place is still true.
They could come in and force that fight if they won.
Why didn't they.
I think the answer is because Pericles had convinced placed on acts of something
that was essentially true and that the Spartans when they had time to cool down
could see that there was some reason for doing this.
And it was this that what happens if we fight.
Look we only fought each other a little while ago and what happened then.
Well you beat us but you didn't clobber us.
You took a lot of.
Casualties and you weren't able to exploit it.
That is even truer today than it was then because if you defeat us what do we
do.
We'll run back to our walls will go through our gates and you won't be able to
lay a pinky on us.
And we don't have to fight you if we don't want to because we own the fleet that
dominates the sea.
We have the money from our airlines that pays for the fleet as long as we have
control of the sea.
You can ravage our country all you want so we can get all the grain we need
through imports.
So what are you going to do then.
You'll have taken casualties for nothing and you still won't be able to compel
us to do what you want.
I think that's the argument that Pericles must have given took place to an ax.
Please don't axe the whole career suggests he was not a man eager for war and he
was glad to have that opportunity to avoid it.
But the amendment the Spartans could have overdone that and they didn't.
And I think it shows you that this was an argument that had some reality and had
some appeal so.
That four month truce was successful.
It led to the negotiation of a peace between Athens on behalf of its allies and
Sparta on behalf of its allies.
The thirty years peace which is concluded in over the winter of 446 445 the
arrangements of that peace are that Athens would give up all of its holdings on
the continent.
That is to say outside the Aegean Sea
except not practice which they would continue to leave in the hands of the
headlines in tacit recognition.
Nobody formally did it but the point is they let the Athenian allies be included
in the Athenian decision that meant the Spartans granted recognized the
legitimate as the legitimacy of the Athenian Empire.
Then they had a few rules meant to prevent the outbreak of war in the future.
And like most of these peace treaties who decide to try to prevent war in the
future they basically look back to how this war started and try to prevent this
war.
Happening again.
For instance this war came about because once it won the ally of one side
changed sides to the other.
That was forbidden under the new treaty and somebody must have thought.
Yeah.
I right.
But what if there's a neutral state that wants to go from one side to the other.
And what if that state has significant strategic importance.
Wouldn't that.
Wouldn't that test the peace at all or would it.
And they concluded it wouldn't because they said neutrals were free to join
either side.
So in other words if a neutral join one side nobody could say OK that's a cause
for war because it wasn't.
And finally the most remarkable and I believe original absolutely original idea
of its kind ever.
I don't believe there's ever a time in history that we have a record of such a
thing being present I'm talking about a clause in the Treaty which provided that
if in the future there were any disagreements between the two signatories.
Any complaints that they had against one another.
These must be submitted to an arbitrator for a decision.
Remind.
Remember I'm not talking about a mediator who says let's talk it over boys.
I'm talking about an arbitrator who has the right and responsibility to say
you're right you're wrong or some version of such a thing.
If that clause had been adhered to.
It's only a matter of logic that says there could never be a war between these
two sides.
It's an amazing idea and I'm going to claim with no proof I'll be doing this
again and again for a while.
I think this is Pericles idea because I mean everything that I'm going to point
to.
That's so unusual and unheard of before Pericles is involved with it.
And I think he just had that kind of mind.
Very inventive ready to find new ways to meet old problems.
I think this was his notion and I'm convinced it was his determination that this
would be the case that in the future there would not be a settlement of
differences by the threat of war but by arbitration.
That helps explain the very determined position he will take in 431.
This is very important.
I don't know how much the Spartans felt that way or knew about what was going to
happen obviously they didn't but they bought it.
That's the treaty.
The two sides swear to it and for 30 years they must adhere to these provisions.
That is the 30 years peace and I think we need to evaluate it to get at this
argument I'm engaged in with the facilities that you're listening in on.
That is
there are pieces and there are pieces they're not all the same.
I'd for my own purposes have come up with I think three categories of peace and
I want to suggest which one this belongs in there is such a thing as a
a
people have spoken of the First World War.
The I'm sorry.
The
peace of her side was often referred to by its critics as a Punic peace.
They're talking about the peace.
They think they're talking about the peace that concluded the second Punic War
with Hannibal.
But no they're talking about the third Punic War in which the peace was the city
of Carthage was destroying.
The castle Virginians were driven away.
Those who were not killed the fields were plowed up and salt put in the furrows.
So they thought nobody could grow anything there again.
That's a Punic piece.
And there's something to be said for a Punic peace you'll never have a war again
with that country because it doesn't exist anymore that's one extreme
at the other extreme is where I suppose
the winning side can can impose a harsh peace but chooses to impose a gentle
peace in the hope that in the future they will have friendly relations with the
other side.
And so they they they trust the other side even though it's not destroyed to be
good.
And if there are such examples of such things they usually a case where the
defeated side has been so weakened that it's highly unlikely in the future that
they will be a problem or another.
Then there's the kind of
back up a step then there's a kind of a peace that people say was represented by
the peace of West failure in 16 48 that ended the 30 years war in Europe.
In which arrangements are made.
Nobody has actually been defeated.
There is no clear cut winner.
There are no just plain losers.
Everybody has fought so long and the cost has been so great that they decided we
can't hold out for victory.
We've got to cut the best deal we can and such a peace.
Depends.
You know it may work it may not.
It depends upon circumstances in the future that are very hard to predict.
And then we come to.
What I think is probably the worst.
Kind of peace.
One example of it is the peace that the Prussians imposed upon the French in
1870 after the Franco Prussian war in which the big issue was they took Alsace
Lorraine from the French and annexed it to Germany at but at the same time they
did not so harm France that France could never again be a menace but they could
be sure that for the foreseeable future and who knows maybe forever the French
would be angry and dissatisfied and determined to recover Alsace Lorraine even
if it meant war.
And that was true to a degree although that we need to be aware that the
evidence the best evidence we have is that by 1914 the French actually had
pretty well given up on Alsace Lorraine although people kept talking as though
that's why the French went to war.
It wasn't true but also there of course there were Frenchmen who did believe
that way.
But on balance it probably wasn't so.
I suppose the best example of that unsatisfactory peace though is the peace that
ended the first world war the peace of our side where the Germans were treated
very harshly in their own opinion although much harsher solutions were available
that were rejected but also they weren't.
They lost a lot of territory and had a lot of restrictions put upon them but
also there was no permanent harm.
That guarantee that Germany would not be able when it recovered from the war to
reverse that decision.
That is the same kind of thing terrible situation in which the defeated power is
totally dissatisfied with the peace and is in a condition down the road to be
strong enough to break now.
Where does the thirty years peace fit in here.
The closest analogy in my opinion is West failure.
I think that the two sides had both found this very unpleasant uncomfortable war
producing dangers and risks that neither had ever anticipated and that the
forces who are in control at the time that the peace was made felt it just
wasn't worth.
Having a fight to the finish for the gains that could be made.
And so this is the key thing
if that is true then peace was possible then the Peloponnesian War that follows
is not inevitable.
Scholars argue still did facility say it was inevitable.
I think he did.
Most scholars do.
Some people think not.
But whatever he may have said
that is certainly a view of many a scholar has taken.
So.
I'm saying no.
And the reason I'm saying that is first of all because of the facts I've just
laid out before you.
But I think also here's this is important.
So much depends not only on objective conditions but on intention.
This is one place where historians differ typically from political scientists
political scientists like to have everything.
What's the word I want.
Not having to do with human intention.
In any case they have to be automatic.
They like to be systemic.
That's what they like.
Nations are billiard balls.
You can't look inside them.
They're not made up of people.
They're not even made up of factions or parties.
The state does what it has to do because of the place on the pool table and
where it is located.
Historians like to ask what were the what were these guys interested in what did
they want.
What were they afraid of.
Who were they mad at.
That's the way proper historians it's true that proper historians are harder and
harder to find.
Too many too many sort of political scientists hidden among the historians
but
the key a key question to whether this war and whether this peace rather will
last has to do with in my opinion with these but these human questions how do
the players really feel about it.
Do they see it as this is the way it's gonna be we want it to be peaceful.
Or are they just accepting it because they can't avoid it.
Well I think the evidence suggests that the people who made the treaty certainly
were persuaded that peace was better than war and they would like to bind their
hands to some degree to make it harder for a war to come out.
Pericles I think will prove that by the time we get a chance to examine his
behavior in 431.
But I think it was the peace party and there are parties in Sparta.
As I've told you before that group of people who typically was conservative and
reluctant to risk what they had already for what they might gain in future
warfare.
And I believe that they were.
The normal party in Sparta and this is all debatable but I think that that's the
normal situation in Sparta to break the peace you need for that situation to be
undone by something and events opportunities fears chances to succeed have to
fall into place in a certain way to break that.
So what I'm telling you is from my point of view it's not at all clear that
there needs to be another war.
Well anybody who says that has the obligation of examining why did the war break
out.
Why did the Peace fail.
And that's what I will turn to next.
I will examine the years between 445 and 430 one in which the peace is tested to
see whether it really had any viability before it failed.
We'll have a look at that next.